hi everyone this is Professor M de
science this video is about the action
of the position and momentum operators
on wave functions when you first learn
about wave functions one of the first
things you learn is that the action of
the position operator is such that it
multiplies a wave function by X and this
sort of makes sense the next thing you
learn is that the action of the momentum
operator acts by calculating the
derivative of a wave function and this
does not always make that much sense
what I want to do in this video is
pretty straight forward I want to show
you that yes the position operator acts
on wave functions by multiplying them by
X and the momentum operator acts on wave
functions by calculating their
derivative so let's go to study the
action of the position and momentum
operators on wave functions let's start
by reminding ourselves of the most
important property of these two
operators which is the fact that their
commutator is equal to IH bar because
wave functions are defined as the
representation of state vector in the
basis spanned by the eigen ket's of the
position operator then the action of the
position operator on wave functions is
trivial to see that let's consider the
eigenvalue equation for the position
operator x hat acting on the cat X is
equal to the eigenvalue x acting on the
cat x we then write an arbitrary state
sy and we consider its representation in
the position basis and to do that we
calculate the bracket of sy with X which
gives us the wave function Phi of X to
see how the position operator acts on
wave functions we start by constructing
the cat sy prime which is equal to the
cat followed by the action of the
position operator on the cat's eye the
next step is to see what the cat sy
prime looks like in the position
representation so we calculate the
bracket between X and PSI prime which
gives us X X hat psi then we recognize
that the action of X hat on the bra X is
equal to the eigenvalue x times the bra
X because the X hat operator is a
hermitian operator and putting this
together we obtain X and then the
bracket between X and PSI which we
recognize as the wave function so we can
write the whole thing as equal to X
multiplying the wave function Phi of X
what does
result imply its telling us that the
action of the position operator on state
sigh in terms of wave functions is
simply multiplying the wave function Phi
of X by X we can repeat the very same
exercise for the momentum operator in
the basis spanned by its own eigen ket's
so we start by considering again an
arbitrary cat's-eye and we write it down
in the momentum basis as the bracket
between P and X I which gives us the
momentum space wave function psy power
of P we then define a new cat sy Prime
in this case being formed by the action
of the momentum operator on the cat's
eye and now we seek again what the cat
sigh prime looks like in the momentum
representation to do that let me project
the cat's-eye Prime on P to then obtain
PP hat sigh we then recognize the action
of P hat on the bra P as simply giving
the eigen value P times the bra P
because P is a hermitian operator and
then we obtain P and the bracket between
PM sy we recognize this bracket as side
bar of P and we can write the whole
thing as equal to P multiplying sy bar
of P so what have we learned we see that
acting with the position operator X hat
on a ket psi is equivalent to
multiplying by X a wave function psi of
X if we work in the position
representation likewise acting with the
momentum operator P hat on a ket psi is
equivalent to multiplying by P the
momentum space wave function psi bar of
P if we work in the momentum
representation so perhaps unsurprisingly
we have seen that the action of the
position operator when written in its
own basis is rather simple and the
action of the momentum operator when
written in its own basis is also rather
simple in the rest of this video we will
consider the much harder question of
what happens when I act with the
momentum operator and I want to describe
that action in the basis of the position
operator or vice versa what happens when
I act with the position operator and I
want to represent that action in the
basis spanned by the momentum eigen
ket's
let's start by considering the action of
the momentum operator in the position
basis which means that we have to
consider wave functions Phi of X to show
this we will need to use some of the
properties of the translation operator
if you need a refresher about
translation operator you can find the
link in the description to a whole video
on that but all I will do here is to
quote the relevant results from that
video a translation by an amount alpha
is described by the translation operator
T alpha which is equal to e to the minus
I alpha P over H bar an infinitesimal
translation by minus epsilon is given by
e to the I epsilon P over H bar which we
can tailor expand to obtain 1 plus I
epsilon over H bar P plus a term of
order epsilon squared
another result we need is that the
action of the translation by alpha on a
ket X is equal to another ket X plus
alpha another corresponding expression
in dual space is such that the bra X
translation operator alpha is equal to
the bra X minus alpha with these two
results we are now ready to start so we
again consider a cat sy and we write it
down in the position representation as X
sy equals the wave function Phi of X and
then we consider a second cat sy prime
which in this case is given by the
action of the momentum operator on the
cat side and what we want to know is
what does this new cat sy prime looks
like in the position representation so
we need to calculate X P hat sy this is
where the translation operator comes in
and we consider the bracket X t minus
epsilon sy we then use the action of the
translation operator on brush to write
this down as the bracket between X plus
epsilon and sy and then we recognize
this as the wave function psi of X plus
Epsilon the next step is to repeat the
same calculation XT minus epsilon upside
but now using the Taylor expansion of
the translation operator so we write X
and then 1 plus I epsilon over h-bar P
plus a term of order epsilon squared sy
and putting this together we obtain x sy
plus I epsilon over h-bar X P hat side
plus a term of order epsilon squared in
this final X
depression exercise is simply the wave
function Phi of X we now recognize that
the term here XP hat psi is precisely
the term we need above and we can
therefore rearrange these two
expressions we have found in order to
write down that XP hat psi is equal to
minus IH bar and then we take the limit
of epsilon going to 0 of psy at X plus
epsilon minus Phi of X all divided by
epsilon and then recognizing that the
limit is simply the definition of a
derivative we can write the whole thing
as minus I h-bar and the relative with
respect to X of psi of X so what does
this mean what we have found is that the
action of the momentum operator P hat on
a state's I when written in the position
representation is such that the momentum
operator calculates the derivative of
the wave function and then multiply the
result by minus I h-bar what we found
earlier is that the action of the
position operator in the position
representation was simply multiplying
the wave function by X and what we have
found now is that the action of the
momentum operator in the position
representation is somewhat more
complicated it calculates the derivative
of the wave function we can now ask the
converse question what happens when we
act with the position operator in the
momentum basis to prove that we will use
the fact that the momentum space wave
function is related to the real space
wave function by a Fourier transform as
written down here and if you need to
reminder about this do check the video
linked in the description we start by
defining a cat sy prime as equal to the
action of the position operator on
another cat sy we then write these two
cats in both momentum and position
representations
subscibe R prime of P is equal to psi
prime sy power of P is equal to psi phi
prime of x is equal to x sy prime and
Phi of X is equal to X sy to understand
how the position operator acts in
momentum space we need to be able to
write sy bar prime of P in terms of
cyber of P to get started we right side
bar prime of P we then use the Fourier
transform relation
buf to set this equal to one over square
root of 2 pi H bar integral over the X e
to the minus IPX over H bar psy prime of
X we know from the beginning of this
video that psy prime of X is simply
equal to X times sine of X because the
position operator acts by multiplying by
X in the position representation we can
therefore write the whole thing as equal
to 1 over square root of 2 pi H bar
integral over the X e to the minus IPX
over H bar X times sine of X to make
progress let me calculate the derivative
with respect to P of e to the minus IPX
over H bar sy of X and to calculate this
derivative all we need to note is that
in this expression the only term that
depends on P is the exponential so we
can write the whole thing as equal to
minus IX over H bar e to the minus IPX
over H bar times Phi of X with a note
that the three terms here X the
exponential and sy of X or precisely the
three terms that we have in the
integrand above X the exponential and sy
of X this tells us we can rewrite
sidebar prime of P as equal to IH bar d
DP of 1 over square root of 2 pi H bar
integral over the X e to the minus IPX
over H bar sy of X where we can take the
derivative with respect to P outside of
the integral because the integral is
over X the last step is to realize that
the term in square brackets is simply
the Fourier transform written above so
it is equal to psi bar of P and we can
write the whole thing as equal to IH bar
and the derivative with respect to P of
side bar P so what do we learn from this
we have that side bar prime of P is
simply the momentum space representation
of the state sy prime which is the state
obtained by acting with the position
operator on state sy and what we can see
is that this action in the momentum
representation is simply equivalent to
differentiating the momentum wave
function with respect to momentum
putting everything together tells us
that in the momentum representation the
action of the momentum operator is
pretty straightforward it's simple
multiplies the momentum wavefunction by
P but the action of the position
operator is more involved because it
requires the calculation of the
derivative with respect to P of the
momentum wavefunction before concluding
I want to generalize these results to
three dimensions so we start with the
position representation where the wave
function psi of R is equal to the
projection of sy on R and in the
position representation the action of
the position operator simply multiplies
the wave function by R where is the
action of the momentum operator is such
that it calculates the gradient of the
wave function with respect to R the same
thing carries through in the momentum
representation where the momentum
wavefunction zhaibar of P is equal to
the projection of the state sy on the
basis P the action of the position
operator calculates the gradient of the
wave function with respect to P and the
action of the momentum operator simply
multiplies the wave function by P to
summarize we have considered the
position and momentum operators and
their commutator which is equal to IH
bar and we have looked at the
representations associated with the
eigen ket's X and P of these two
operators state sy in the position
representation is given by the wave
function Phi of X which is obtained by
projecting the state psi onto the basis
state X and the action of the position
operator X hat in the position
representation simply multiplies the
wave function by X where is the action
of the momentum operator in the position
representation calculates the derivative
of the wave function with respect to X
and multiply the result by minus IH bar
the results in the momentum
representation are in a sense
complementary to those in the position
representation so the wave function is
sy bar of P which is the projection of
the state psi onto the basis ket P the
action of the position operator is such
that it calculates the derivative of the
wave function with respect to P and then
multiply the result by IH bar and the
action of the momentum operator is
simply multiplicative the results we
have obtained in this video show that
although the represent
stations of quantum states in different
bases are entirely equivalent the
mathematical representation of these
states and of the operators that act on
these states are different between
different representations and the common
theme when solving quantum mechanical
problems is to find the best
representation that makes the
mathematics as easy as possible so what
have we learned we have learned about
the action of the position and momentum
operators on wave functions we can now
solve many quantum mechanical problems
in the wave mechanics formulation
problems that we can solve using this
formulation include potential barriers
and potential wells as well as the
hydrogen atom if you liked the video
please subscribe